الانفجار السكاني يقترب شيئا فشيئا فبحسب
تقارير امميه يصل تعداد سكان العالم الى 8
مليار نسمه في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني ما
يثير مخاوف مصريه بشان محاولات سد الفجوه
بين الزياده السكانيه وموارد بلد يصنف ضمن
اكثر ثمان دول في العالم من حيث زياده
الكثافه السكانيه معدل النمو السكاني
العالمي اا اقل من واحد احنا في مصر 1.8
ده معناه ان احنا بنزيد سنويا اا مليون
و800,000
ده معناه ان احنا في خلال خمس سنين زدنا 9
مليون نسمه يعني مصر كل عشر سنين يضاف
اليها دوله محاولات الدوله المصريه ووضع
خطه قصيره او طويله الامل للحد من الزياده
السكانيه لا تتوقف فما بين توسع في
المشروعات السكانيه وزياده مساحه الرقعه
الزراعيه وتطوير البنى التحتيه الا ان
معدل الزياده السكانيه يسير بوتره اسرع من
تلك المحاولات
عندنا تحتيه لاي دوله وكل مكان فيه ضغط
على الخدمات المقدمه في الرعايه الصحيه
والاجتماعيه وخلافه وكل ذلك كل ما زال
معدات الفقر
والبطاله فهي دائره مفرغه كل ما زاد عدد
السكان وكثافه السكان في منطقه ماء كل ما
زادت المشاكل المرتبطه بالسكان وخصائص
السكان
الجهاز المركزيه للتعبئه العامه والاحصاء
المصريه فانه بحلول عام 2030 ليصلوا تعداد
سكان مصر
و 120 مليون نسمه ما يعني تباط الاجهزه
المعنيه في تنفيذ استراتيجيه الدوله
الهادفه للحد من الانفجار السكاني